foreign
back to Long crime daily everybody we
are closely following a capital murder
sentencing in Texas a former border
patrol agent could soon find himself on
death row a jury found Ronald Anthony
Burgos Aviles guilty of murder in Laredo
Texas last week that immediately kicked
off The Penalty phase of the trial Virgo
saviles was charged in 2018 with the
deaths of his mistress Griselda
Hernandez and their one and a half year
old son Dominic prosecutors argued that
Dominic was born while the defendant was
having an affair and Hernandez served
him child support documents because of
that prosecutors say he stabbed
Hernandez and the baby to death after
meeting up with them near a park another
week of evidence is expected as part of
that penalty phase the jury will then
hand down a recommendation for either
the death penalty or life in prison
without Parole in court on Monday
griselda's mom who sometimes called her
daughter gray testified about the effect
these murders have had on her family
including griselda's oldest son Jaden
who was six when his mom was killed
came apart
I couldn't believe it
especially dominant
it's been very very very hard
it has totally changed our lives
do you
and
Jaden ever go into her room
yes
Jayden asks Grandma can we go into Mom's
room that room is locked
she let everything is still the same the
way she left it
but sometimes Jaden wants to go into her
mom her mom's room
so I go with him
he just wants to be there for a little
while
he goes to his mom's bed
I was like there's a perfect
looking at the ceiling
I don't know what crosses his mind
but it has impacted him so much
Brian let's talk about the defense for a
second because they're arguing that a
cocktail of testosterone and
prescription drugs led to psychosis and
his law enforcement background that all
of this should spare him being killed is
that going to be winning an argument is
that a winning argument do you think
he'll actually be spared
I think it's the best argument they have
it's a creative argument and I'll
separate it into the two the law
enforcement one great throw it out there
but the question becomes how good of an
officer do you have to be to mitigate
the fact that you stab the mother of
your child in an eight and your 18 month
old child to death to avoid child
support you got to be a really good law
enforcement agent I don't think that's
enough here The psychosis aspect is
great but don't forget it's the same
jury for weeks you've been saying it
wasn't him it wasn't him it wasn't him
then all of a sudden you pivot and say
well it's these cocktail of drugs I
don't think it's going to pass a lab
test I don't or the sniff test or
whatever test you want to call it I
think the jury's going to catch on and
say you know what don't really buy it
Philip yeah he stabbed the mother of his
child this baby he stabbed this baby to
death is there really anything he could
do to save himself because that feels
really hard to get past for a jury
remember the test is whether or not the
aggravators outweigh the mitigators what
do we have here first of all he has
absolutely no criminal record at least
that I'm aware of and usually the death
penalty is reserved for the worst of the
worst and obviously if this is his only
crime he started off with a Dilly I
understand that but this was not
committed in my opinion in his capacity
as a law enforcement officer everybody
seems to suggest at least in social
media that because he's a cop who did
this he should die for it but he did
this in his capacity as a father with a
mistress and I'm not sure that it's
enough he's entitled to a loss of human
emotion to get life without parole I
can't say which way the jury is going to
go but looking at the picture of his son
his baby son that I feel is gonna be
really hard to get past
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we are
bringing you a brand new trial out of
Phoenix Arizona involving defendant
Michael Turney the 75 year old is
charged in the murder of his
stepdaughter almost 20 years after the
crime The Story begins in May of 2001.
seventeen-year-old Alyssa Turney was in
her last day of junior year at Paradise
Valley High School she told her
boyfriend that her stepfather Michael
Turney was taking her out of school
early and she was never seen again
attorney reported Alyssa missing to
police saying she ran away he told
investigators that Alyssa left a note
behind saying she was going to
California the case went cold until 2006
when a false confession brought it back
into the spotlight in 2008 it was
determined by The Missing Persons unit
that Foul Play was involved in sexual
abuse allegations against tourney
pointed authorities in his Direction
police searched attorney's home and
found assault rifles handmade silencers
gasoline cans more than 20 pipe bombs
and a Manifesto in which tourney accused
his co-workers of killing Alyssa
attorney was sentenced to 10 years in
federal prison for illegal weapons
possession and was released in 2017 in
the following years Alyssa's half-sister
started a podcast and a tick tock
account to bring awareness to the story
and in August of 2020 19 years after
Alyssa's disappearance attorney was
arrested and charged with second-degree
murder to this day Alyssa's body has
never been found Monday marked the
second day of his trial on the second
day that Alyssa's half-sister Sarah
testified for the prosecution here's
some highlights from Monday's testimony
you recognize the um this document yes
and what is it please that's the note
that was on her dresser
the note that you found yes next to the
cell phone yes so let's just talk about
the first
line when you drop me off at school
today did you drop her off at school no
I mean
she was gone when you got up right
correct
and this is addressed to Dad and Sarah
Sarah you said you didn't want me around
look you got it based upon the nature of
your relationship with your sister at
the time
does that
make sense to you
no there was no big fight or anything
before we before she was gone did you
want her out of your life forever no why
not
who on occasion asked your father
what happened to Alyssa many times has
he ever given you
an answer
he told me he told me on his Deathbed
and when did he make that statement
I met up with him at a Starbucks in
October of 2017 to meet him face to face
and finally get some answers she was
impulsive
times
and she talked about leaving often
didn't she
no
you told detective Anderson that she
talked about leaving often
that's probably how I felt at the time
no signs of The Struggle No
didn't smell like any cleaning supplies
had been recently used
recall
didn't notice any blood in her room no
so Brian Turney he spent 10 years in
federal prison for having the pipe bombs
the manifesto claiming that he wanted to
kill his colleagues who as I said he
believed were responsible for Alyssa's
disappearance is any of that going to
come up in the case
typically I would say no because the
question becomes what's the relevance
how how does this pipe bomb in this gun
and this Manifesto and wanting to kill
your co-workers connect to the alleged
murder of your stepdaughter but if I'm
the defense attorney I'm throwing it in
there because you have to then believe
that he went through this entire plan
getting all these ammunitions all this
guns he willingly did 10 years in jail
instead of saying hey guys it's a hoax
whatever it is to try to throw the scent
off of him that's got to be the craziest
alternative plan hey I'm going to do 10
years in federal prison to try to throw
the scent off of me for an actual murder
that I committed if you believe that
then maybe the defense can Prevail well
Phillip police thought this case was a
runaway case for seven years and the
only arrest attorney 20 years later that
time is that going to hurt the
prosecution's case not in this case at
all and I'll tell you why first of all
this is a classic example of why murder
does not have a statute of limitations
initially insufficient evidence is just
that they don't have probable cause or
enough evidence to make an arrest but
sufficiency and evidence can develop
over time and let's see what they got do
they have for example any DNA any
serological evidence any other forensics
do they have any digital evidence is
there maybe even Botanical evidence that
could tie him to a homicide or maybe
there was some type of forfeiture by
wrongdoing where he threatened her and
it's going to come in through the sister
it's just pretty incredible that we're
here and having a trial of this case
after so many years